[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURA PARAGANO:
Welcome everybody,
thanks so much for joining us.
DUKE ERIKSON: Thanks
everybody for being here.
STEVE MARKER: Thanks for coming.
LAURA PARAGANO: Big welcome
obviously to Garbage.
Thank you so much
for joining us today
at Google, to talk about
technology and how it affects
the creative process.
I'm Laura Paragano.
Please make sure to silence
your cell phones, everybody.
AUDIENCE: Silence is golden.
LAURA PARAGANO: Yes.
DUKE ERIKSON: Ah.
SHIRLEY MANSON: Beautiful.
LAURA PARAGANO: Since
their formation in 1993,
Garbage has sold over 17
million albums worldwide.
And they even recorded
the theme song
for "The World is Not Enough,"
the 19th James Bond movie.
So thank you so much, Duke,
Steve, Shirley, and Butch
for joining us.
You are on your 20th anniversary
tour of "Version 2.0."
2.0, obviously, it's
a technological phrase
to describe the
evolution of something.
When you were
recording the album,
how did you feel like this was
a progression of yourselves
as a band?
BUTCH VIG: I think
what we learned
in our debut record was that we
kind of came up with a sound.
And one conscious
decision that we
made when we started
our second album was we
did not want to
reinvent ourselves.
We wanted to take everything
we learned and raise the bar.
And so it's sort
of tongue in cheek.
That's why it's
called, "Version 2.0."
But that's also the
first record that we
dove into the digital world.
We started working
with Pro Tools.
And haven't really looked back.
I mean, that
clearly was becoming
the wave of the future.
So that's kind of why we
call it "Version 2.0."
Not even so much
tongue in cheek.
We just felt like it was a
new, bigger, faster, better,
stronger, updated
version of Garbage.
LAURA PARAGANO: Did
that affect the process
of writing the album or just
the production side of things?
DUKE ERIKSON: I think
it affected everything.
The technology,
they work together,
the technology and the creative
sides, kind of fed one another.
And I think calling
it "Version 2.0,
we were hoping it was also
an upgrade in the songwriting
and the music itself, it wasn't
just about the technology.
LAURA PARAGANO:
Yeah, in the process
of now playing it
20 years later,
you've had to adjust
to perform it live.
And it's a trend
nowadays, it seems
like, artists playing
seminal albums in full.
Has the process of
playing it changed
since the time of recording it?
SHIRLEY MANSON: Not really.
[LAUGHS] I mean, the weird
thing is, 20 years ago, we
were pretty forward thinking.
And a lot of the
software developers and
so on and so forth
were very enamored
with Butch's production
career and really directed
a lot of their
prototypes towards him
and our engineer at the time.
And so we were forward thinking.
And we brought it
to the live setting,
we encountered a
lot of hostility,
I think is the best
way of putting it.
Because we did incorporate the
technology into our live show.
And this was seen back
then as a sort of sin.
You know, you're not real
musicians, you're cheaters,
you're fakers.
I mean, it sounds
hysterical now,
but 20 years ago
it felt very real.
And we were a little
daunted by the hostility
that we met from reviewers.
Now, of course, 20
years on, everybody's
doing basically what we
were doing back then.
LAURA PARAGANO: Drum pads--
SHIRLEY MANSON: Yeah.
BUTCH VIG: And loops
and sequencers.
And we actually got
a threat from someone
in Australia, who said
if you come to Australia
and play with this
technology, you're
going to get booed off stage.
And we were like really?
Because they really
wanted [INAUDIBLE]..
Anyway, we went to Australia
a lot, and they loved us.
So--
LAURA PARAGANO: Shows them.
SHIRLEY MANSON: But our process
has basically stayed the same
for the last 20 years.
And we've seen our approach
be incorporated basically
by mainstream artists,
and everybody's
doing it, kind of, now.
But back then, we were
definitely one of the first
to cheat.
[LAUGHTER]
BUTCH VIG: The good thing
is, it was daunting.
Our engineer, Billy Bush--
we had to scratch our
heads to try and figure out
how do we take the studio sound,
which was quite complicated
on the first record,
and take it to a stage.
And I don't know if all
of you remember ADATs.
We put some backing
tracks in ADATs.
We had weird click tracks
that I would listen to,
and cue with the band.
You guys had these
guitar pedals.
It was a mismatch of stuff.
We had inner ears, plus
also wedges on stage.
STEVE MARKER: Midi guitars.
BUTCH VIG: Midi
guitars, which were
really slow to play and
actually to do a patch changing.
But every tour, we got better.
And it's to the point now where
the technology is incredible.
And I run a Ableton
launch pad behind me.
And when we start a song, after
Shirley cues it, I hit it,
and it sets everything
on the stage,
sets the guitars, the
keyboards, the bass,
everything in my drums.
I'm playing a full electronic
drum kit now, a Roland TD-50.
And it sounds incredible.
And it was a lot
harder 20 years ago
to kind of pull a sound off.
But now I think we probably
sound closer to our albums
than we ever have.
LAURA PARAGANO:
Because of the quality
of the digital instruments?
BUTCH VIG: And because we're
just way better musicians now.
[LAUGHTER]
DUKE ERIKSON: That's
right, I like that answer.
BUTCH VIG: After 20
years of practice,
we're finally learning how
to play some of the songs.
LAURA PARAGANO: Yeah, I was
talking to Duke earlier,
and he said that you actually
don't play with amps on stage
at all, it's fully--
STEVE MARKER: No amps.
LAURA PARAGANO: --plugged
into the system.
SHIRLEY MANSON: We have
a completely clean stage,
which again, we sort
of attempted back then,
and people were horrified.
Like where are your amps?
But we thought it was
thrilling to utilize
the technology that way.
And so even on this tour,
in homage to 20 years ago,
we have a completely bare stage.
There's no equipment that
you can see at all, aside
from old-school analog
keyboards, and a mic stand,
and a drum kit.
STEVE MARKER: And no sound,
other than your voice.
SHIRLEY MANSON: Yeah.
STEVE MARKER: Which really
helps the front of the house.
DUKE ERIKSON: And
tap, tap, tap, tap.
STEVE MARKER: A little tapping.
SHIRLEY MANSON: The greatest
sort of development in my life
currently has been
his electronic kit.
Because as a singer, the
old-school drum kits just
bleed into your mic and
it creates havoc on stage.
And so now, God bless
him, he has a silent kit.
So all the bleed
that traditionally
would come through my mic
and cloud the sound is gone.
So we can get really
clear signals up front,
and it makes it so much easier
for our front of house to mix.
And also, it's just joyous
to have a quiet drummer.
[LAUGHTER]
LAURA PARAGANO: Never happens.
That preempts my
next question, which
I was going to say if you could
bring any piece of technology
now back in time to
when you were recording,
what would it be?
It sounds like maybe
that's a huge sell for you,
to be able to have
that clarity of sound.
I don't know if--
SHIRLEY MANSON: That
would be amazing.
LAURA PARAGANO: --anybody
else has a different answer.
BUTCH VIG: The great
thing about technology
is it gets better and
usually cheaper every year.
It's not something where the
price, the better it gets,
the more expensive it gets.
So it's just made our
whole world much easier.
And I wish, quite frankly,
when we started out
with the technology,
we'd be where it is now.
It would've been so much easier.
There was a lot of head
scratching, and agony,
and just freaking
out, trying to figure
how to do it on the first tour.
But somehow, we made it through.
LAURA PARAGANO: What
was like the hardest
thing on the first tour?
Or which aspect of the
technological nuances?
BUTCH VIG: For me, we put like--
so if you understand,
there's a lot
of loops and things
in the Garbage songs.
So we would take the
loops off the record,
I would play live
drums over them.
But to get the--
to be able to play
those back, we
had to put the loops from
the record on a ADAT,
and Shirley would write
up the set every night,
but back then, you had to
hit fast forward and rewind.
So depending on where the set
was, oh, my god, the first song
is the first song, and then
the 20th song on the ADAT
is the second song.
So I'd go, OK, talk, Shirley,
talk, I'm fast forwarding,
talk.
And it only took
sometimes 15 seconds
to go with that, or
20 seconds, but that
can seem like an
eternity on the stage
if Shirley's not talking
while I'm standing there.
So that used to be my biggest
freak out every night,
like let's trying to get a
set list that I'm not fast
forwarding and rewinding
between the songs.
SHIRLEY MANSON: Yeah, so we
weren't able to really change
things up as much.
Now we are as free, as a
result of the technology,
as just a normal
hard-working musician.
It's so adaptable
now and so quick
that we can do
things on the fly,
and we never were able
to do that 20 years ago.
DUKE ERIKSON: We did
two songs on a talk show
in Paris, and the
little ADAT thing--
SHIRLEY MANSON: Oh, god, yeah.
DUKE ERIKSON: The ADAT
thing wouldn't work,
and Butch is back there
going-- like that.
SHIRLEY MANSON: On live TV.
STEVE MARKER: National TV.
DUKE ERIKSON: Live to the air.
BUTCH VIG: It had shut down.
It had gone to sleep
while we went off stage.
And it was all cued up but
the power was off on it.
And I hit go, and it's warming
up, warming up-- oh, fuck,
we're just standing there,
everyone's staring at me.
[LAUGHTER]
We've learned to play the
songs with our bass player--
Eric, from Jane's
Addiction plays with us.
He's incredible.
I can play drums.
These guys can play guitars.
If the loops don't
work, we can still play.
But it sounds more
like the record
if we have the percussion loops
or the crazy sound effects
and stuff.
So we do like to rely on it.
When it doesn't work,
we just go old school
and play two guitars,
bass drums and vocal.
We're more sort of
unplugged at that point,
but we can still do it.
LAURA PARAGANO: Absolutely.
In general, as
like a philosophy,
do you try to stay as close to
the album sound as possible,
or have you explored
evolving in any way,
or changing in any way that
sound to a live experience?
SHIRLEY MANSON: Not really,
because the layering of sounds
and the utilizing of all the
different samples and loops
and so on, became the
signature sound of our band.
And again, going
back 20 years, we
met with a lot of hostility
because of the way
that we put records together.
But as a result, we
developed a sound of ours
that's really unique to us.
So we do try and make sure we
have these layers, upon layers,
upon layers all the time.
Because that's what
makes us sound like us.
And we're proud of that.
To have your own unique
sound in a landscape
where you literally have
millions and millions of bands
at this point, is really
rare and obviously
of great value to us.
LAURA PARAGANO: Yeah, given
that you are so layer heavy
and now it's even easier
to make those layers,
has that changed
your songwriting
process for the better?
Has it made it smoother?
Has it almost made it
harder, because there's
so many loops that you
can make and sounds
that you can work with?
BUTCH VIG: We kind of lost
our minds on "Version 2.0."
We had done the first
record on 48 track.
In fact, some of the songs
on our debut album we're just
on 24 track analog tape.
And when we got Pro
Tools, we realized,
you can record as many
tracks as you want.
And there were
three or four songs,
like "Hammering in my
Head," and "Push It,"
maybe a couple more that
had over 200 tracks,
like had 225 or 230 tracks.
Clearly, we did not
know how to self edit
at the time, which became
a problem in mixing,
because as we were
trying to figure out
what we should
leave in the song,
we had a lot of
decision making to do.
I think we've gotten better
at that now, quicker.
We just, rather than have
25 options for the guitar
solo or whatever,
we pretty much get
one sound and we stick with it.
DUKE ERIKSON: One take.
[LAUGHTER]
STEVE MARKER: Yeah right.
LAURA PARAGANO:
Your professionals.
STEVE MARKER: Yeah.
BUTCH VIG: But the
technology is--
the great thing
about that too is
that the way we
work as a band is,
we usually come in
with a song idea,
and it could come from someone
that has a chord progression.
It could be from a title.
Shirley might just
have a title, or Steve
might have a guitar
riff, or whatever.
We jam and come up
with a little fragment.
And then typically, how we
work is it's like a canvas.
We throw a lot of things at it.
We keep adding sounds
and taking things away.
And the song can sound
one way at the start,
and by the end of it, it's
radically different sounding.
And sometimes we change
the tempo and keys.
Usually, it isn't until she
Shirley finishes her lyrics
that that sort of
dictates to us more how it
should sound arrangement wise.
But the songs take a journey.
And we couldn't do it
without the technology.
You know, if we were trying to
work that way with analog tape
back in the day, we just
couldn't make the records
that we make now.
LAURA PARAGANO: It would
take like two minutes just
to rewind and listen
to it again, I'm sure.
DUKE ERIKSON:
That's right, yeah.
LAURA PARAGANO: So how
do you know when to stop?
I mean, obviously,
the lyrics help,
but I think when you're
working with layers,
or you can have the
vocals and still
have it go towards
a different mood.
Are there some songs that have
kind of just like flown out
and some that take a
lot more processing?
SHIRLEY MANSON: It's usually
when I say that's enough.
STEVE MARKER: Yeah.
BUTCH VIG: Yeah.
SHIRLEY MANSON:
That's enough of that.
STEVE MARKER:
You've had your fun.
SHIRLEY MANSON: Yeah.
To be honest, I mean, it usually
is that just, sort of like,
OK, we need to chill now.
Like, this is good,
let's put it out,
let's move forward
with our lives.
I mean, is that fair?
BUTCH VIG: That's true.
Left to our devices,
Duke, and Steve,
and I would probably just
keep twiddling away--
I've got another
idea for the verse
here, or whatever, because we
are kind of a nerdy lab rats.
I mean, that's
what we like to do.
But Shirley just puts her foot
down, and then the song's done.
[LAUGHTER]
LAURA PARAGANO: Amazing.
We were talking about
how you, as a band,
were one of the first to come
into this digital space that
includes not just production
and the creative process,
but also engaging
with audiences.
Shirley, you were
one of the first
to have a blog where
you're talking to fans.
How has that impacted the
experience of connection
with those individuals?
SHIRLEY MANSON: That's
a good question.
I mean, I think I was
actually the first to be
directly communicating
with an audience online.
And I'm not entirely
sure what drove
me to do that, other
than somebody had said,
you know, you can
keep a diary of what's
going on in the
studio if you want,
and then we'll post
it to the fans.
It was somebody at
the record label.
And I was like, yeah, OK.
And because I was isolated.
I was living in
Madison, Wisconsin.
I couldn't drive.
I I still didn't
really have any money.
I don't have a credit card.
I was so isolated.
And so the ability
to communicate
with an outside life was
extraordinary for me.
And Steve did some of it too.
And the impact has
been sort of profound
and has grown exponentially
over the last 20 years for us.
And we have a pretty tight
relationship with our fans
through social
media as a result.
And we've never abused it.
And we've never allowed
it to get too intrusive.
But it has been a
remarkable tool for us,
particularly in the
first two records.
There was a lot of
inaccuracies written up
about us in the press.
Then all of the sudden,
we had this ability
to counteract what
was fake news.
We could counteract
it with our own voice.
And as a result, you
can sort of relax,
because you know that
you have an ability
to communicate with
you're following,
which is, quite frankly, the
only people we care about.
We don't really care about
people who don't know us,
don't like us, who
gives a shit, you know.
But with the fans, it matters
what they think to us,
and what they hear, and
what they read about.
And so social media
has given us an ability
to directly respond to them
and put falsities right.
And that is an incredible
tool for a musician.
LAURA PARAGANO: Yeah,
they're very much one
to many platforms,
so I could see
that being a great opportunity
to be your authentic self
to a lot of people.
Have you ever experienced
the other side of that,
where you get feedback
through those blogs,
or you hear something
from fans and it's
affected the way you've
tried to create music?
SHIRLEY MANSON: Not so
much tried to create music.
I mean, I'm lucky,
I'm like a bulldog.
You can say stuff to me
and it'll piss me off,
but it won't
necessarily shake me.
I'm hard to shake.
So I don't allow outside
opinions necessarily
to change the way that
we approach music.
I think that'd be
very dangerous.
We're not here to
pleasure other people.
We're here to
pleasure ourselves.
This is a selfish endeavor
amongst the four of us.
And if you like it, you like it.
If you don't connect
with it, that's fine.
But yeah, I don't listen
to that kind of input.
At the same time, I have
been taught enormous lessons
by fans over the years,
in all aspects of my life.
And they've put me right
about a lot of stuff.
They have educated me for stuff
I'm incredibly grateful for.
And they have turned me
on to music I would never,
ever of heard of.
So that's magic, you
know, it's really magical.
LAURA PARAGANO: What
advice would you
give to musicians who
are able to utilize some
of those free tools or
now have the opportunity
to make quality music much
easier than you had originally?
BUTCH VIG: Well,
I think you really
have to try and find your own
voice As Shirley mentioned
earlier, there's millions
and millions of bands
now on YouTube.
And quite frankly, we're kind
of awash in a sea of mediocrity.
I mean, there's a lot
of interesting music.
But in order to really have
your music heard as an artist,
you have to be really good.
It has to rise above
the rest somehow.
And I think the only
way you can really
do that is you have
to be authentic.
You can't seem fake or try to
chase some trend because you
think it'll be popular.
I think people know now when
they latch on to a new artist,
they can tell if
they're authentic
and if they're saying
something that is real.
So that's the one thing
I try to tell people,
that you have to try and
find that authenticity
and follow that.
Because you're also going to
be much happier if you do that.
If you try to become something
else just to become famous,
and you don't like
what you're doing,
you're going to be miserable.
So try to follow
your true heart.
LAURA PARAGANO: Do you feel
like it's a double-edged sword
of making authentic music that
maybe is not as sellable or not
easily--
get into a broader audience that
could then hear, and therefore
allow for creation
of more music?
SHIRLEY MANSON: Well,
it takes courage
to be different from
the rest of the crowd.
Because we are living
currently in a society
that wants immediate results.
So for a young artist to
emerge, to practice patience,
and to pursue their
own way forward
is becoming rarer,
and rarer, and rarer.
Because people understand
they have a nanosecond
to make an impact.
And once they've
made the impact,
they have to then
build on that impact.
And the pressure on young
artists is astounding.
And you see them all come
and go, I mean they're here
and they're huge.
Like what Butch says, they'll
have a million followers
for like five minutes, and then
you never hear of them again.
And we've been really lucky
to have enjoyed a long career.
And we understand
what that takes.
And what that takes is just
an ability to sit in failure.
Failure is part of the role--
I'm sure for you as
designers and creators,
you understand what
I mean by that.
It's difficult not to be
successful all the time
and not to be igniting
people's excitement.
But at the same time,
I'm a great believer,
we all are, in the band,
of you do the work,
and you do the work
because you care about it,
and because you
are invested in it,
and you have your own style.
And sooner or later,
it's like putting pennies
in a piggy bank, you know, you
start to accrue a currency,
an agency.
But that takes, that's painful.
[LAUGHS] And
unfortunately, young people
can't always sustain
that kind of hit.
So yes, it's absolutely
a double-edged sword.
You can get seen immediately.
But then do you have what it
takes to get to the next level
and maintain attention.
LAURA PARAGANO: What
would your advice
be for someone who hits
that level of failure,
to push through and continue
making something authentic?
BUTCH VIG: Write a hit single.
[LAUGHTER]
STEVE MARKER:
That's a good idea.
SHIRLEY MANSON: Don't
we all wish that.
BUTCH VIG: Yeah, that
always seems to work.
LAURA PARAGANO: Do you feel like
technology has made it easier
to fail faster?
Because we often
say here fail fast,
fail often, as a way to
overcome that fear of failure.
I'm not sure if that's
something where,
by being able to make
music faster, in some ways,
or sketch out ideas, you
can see that it's not
going to lead down a particular
path that feels true or right
to the intention of the song.
BUTCH VIG: Well, everything
is being consumed so fast now.
I mean, the whole generation
of kids, like my daughter's 12,
and just to see what
her classmates, how
they absorb music, and
their attention span
is so brief these days.
I think I read
something last year
that the average
length of a song played
is about 45 seconds now.
As soon as it gets the
chorus, they just, boom,
go to the next song.
Which is, to me, is
just really depressing.
Because they never allow
themselves to sort of
engage in that full experience
of what it was like when
that person wrote that song.
We're a firm believer in--
I mean, we're old
school, but we still
like to make albums,
where you sit down
and listen to a piece of
music all the way through.
But we're--
[APPLAUSE]
Obviously, we're not of the
new millennial generation.
So there's a whole
different mindset out there.
And I think it's, like what
Shirley was saying, it's tough.
You have to have
some patience and be
willing to just persevere
through whatever it takes,
whether it's writing,
or the ups and downs,
and try to not worry about
if you think your music is
disappearing quick.
You just have to keep at it,
you just have to keep writing.
You probably have to keep
writing faster than we do.
We're not the
speediest band when
it comes to making an album.
But I know a lot of
talented musicians now,
they can crank out
a song and sometimes
really good, in
like 24, 48 hours.
And the production is amazing.
And the songs are good.
And to me, that's
incredibly cool.
LAURA PARAGANO: Awesome, yeah.
You were saying that people only
listen to the first 45 seconds,
and obviously, you
can make a great song
and have it be complex enough
that perhaps someone will
listen through.
But it seems like
now 65% of sales
come from streaming services,
where that album concept kind
of gets dissipated, and
it's so easy for someone
to listen to a single song.
Do you, as a band,
feel that pressure
to focus at all on singles?
Or it sounds like you still
very much care about the album,
but is in the back
of your mind ever?
SHIRLEY MANSON: Be the
change you want to see.
You can fall in with the
crowd and be swept along
with the tides of
the day, but I think
there's a lot to be said
for, we believe in this,
this is what we'll stand behind.
And again, like I
said, it takes courage.
And it takes-- there's a
lot of failure as a result,
because you're not
falling in with the tide.
But over a course of time, that
can actually be in your favor.
We've been playing
now for 25 years.
We've got an incredible
discography as a result.
And we can play around with
that and create great shows that
are different every
time, because we
have a breadth of material that
singles-orientated bands don't
have.
To go out and play
a show of just hit
singles doesn't really--
generally speaking, it's
just not that interesting.
And then you see an
artist like Nick Cave,
who has never had a hit
single in his entire career--
arguably, in the
UK, with "Kylie".
But generally
speaking, as an artist,
he's just done his own thing,
and he's done it slowly
and incrementally.
And now, we're seeing
him fill stadiums.
And yet, he is like as
alternative and sort
of cross like anti-pop.
And yet he's got the career
that pop stars dream of.
And that's what I believe in.
And that's what I
want to invest in.
I don't really care
about being fashionable
or the sound of the moment.
It's like we wear
that for a moment,
and then inevitably,
that passes,
you're no longer the zeitgeist,
so where do you go then?
What do you do with your
creative energy after that?
And that's, to me, exciting.
LAURA PARAGANO: Do you feel
like you still have the pressure
to play those hit singles?
Or because you don't necessarily
care about the zeitgeist,
that you're able to say, I'm
going to play a single album,
and that'll be the
entire concert?
SHIRLEY MANSON:
Well, the concert
that we're currently
doing, half of the material
is songs that nobody's
ever heard before.
And what is really
exciting about it,
although we were
nervous about it
beforehand, if you create
enough magic, sonic magic,
emotional magic, people
are invested in that,
they're invested
in that journey.
They will listen.
And if the songs
are good enough,
which we think they are,
people come along with you.
And they seem to respond
to that sort of risk.
Everybody enjoys
unexpected, like experience.
It's like breaking an algorithm.
You know, all of
a sudden you're,
like, whoa, OK, this is
actually tremendously
successful for us,
at a time when it
could have gone the other way.
LAURA PARAGANO: What do you all
feel is the role of an artist?
Is that to make magic?
Just to be authentic
for yourselves?
To try and communicate
a particular message
to your listeners?
SHIRLEY MANSON: Connect,
connect, connection.
That's how I see it.
I don't know if everyone
else sees it that way.
BUTCH VIG: Shirley
mentioned this earlier,
we make music for the
four of ourselves.
It's a very intimate process.
And fascinating, and
sometimes frustrating,
and we can get very emotional.
We produce and all
co-write together.
So it is a democracy.
And it's not easy
being in a band where
everybody has an equal voice.
Most of bands I've produced,
there's one leader.
And in some ways,
those are easier bands
to deal with, because
you go to one person
to get decisions made.
But I think because
we work this way is
why we sound like we are.
And it's just, there's something
about when we create music,
we need to express how we
feel, through Shirley's lyrics
and just sonically
what we're doing.
I think the great
thing that we've
found is, especially
on this tour is,
playing these obscure
songs, that the music
has connected and really
touched a lot of our fans.
And that is really
an incredible,
we just want to say thank
you for letting us know that.
Because we make music
in a bubble and we
have no idea if we
will connect or not.
And I think we're
very lucky that we
do have a lot of fans who
really take heart to what we do.
And our fans are the reason
we're here today, why
we get to keep making music.
So it's connecting,
you make music
to hopefully connect on some
sort of emotional level.
LAURA PARAGANO: Do you
wish that you can make it
outside of a bubble?
Or do you appreciate being
able to come together
as just the four
of you and focus
without needing to think
outside of this group?
STEVE MARKER: I think we've
benefited a lot from being
from Madison, Wisconsin, where
there's no record industry
and we were very, very insular.
Nobody was telling
us what to do.
We didn't really know what
was going on on the coasts,
to tell you the truth,
which I think was good.
They just left us alone.
And then we get signed
to some big labels.
So yeah, I think the four
people in a small room trying
to come up with something
doesn't always work,
but when it does,
it's really cool,
and that process is
really precious to us.
And I think we
want to keep that.
BUTCH VIG: Yeah,
the few times we
worked with outside producers--
STEVE MARKER: It didn't work.
BUTCH VIG: It didn't work.
SHIRLEY MANSON: [LAUGHS]
LAURA PARAGANO: You couldn't
see the creative vision through.
BUTCH VIG: We tried it
just because we were just
trying to do something
new at the time,
and it just didn't work.
I think, because the four
of us are so opinionated,
you can't have a fifth opinion.
We have done a bunch of
one-off like record store day
collaborations, with
Brody from the Distillers,
and Brian Aubert from
Silversun Pickups.
And we have a new
one coming out.
But those are just
one-off songs.
It's really fun to do that,
because when you do that,
with another artist, that puts
you in a different head space.
You want to meet them
and then sort of figure
out what they're going to do.
And you get feedback
off that person.
That's always fresh for
us, because usually it's
just the four of us and our
engineer, Billy, in a room
together.
So when you do get that chance
to go with someone else,
it's cool.
It's just another
perspective, which is good.
LAURA PARAGANO: Speaking a
little bit on collaboration,
I know you guys have
heard about Magenta, which
is a Google project that's
using artificial intelligence
to create a different--
BUTCH VIG: Put us
out of business.
[LAUGHTER]
LAURA PARAGANO: That
is not their intention,
as I was told to mention.
Have you collaborated with a
technological entity like that
before?
What do you think is that
kind of project's role
in the creative process?
BUTCH VIG: I don't know.
I'm curious to see.
We're going to it today, right?
STEVE MARKER: We
haven't seen it yet.
DUKE ERIKSON: We
BUTCH VIG: Every
now and then, we
get asked a question
about can technology
make music as good as humans.
And I'm sure that there are
algorithms that could come up
with interesting
chord progressions
and great melodies and stuff.
To me, the most
important thing, for me,
personally, about a song, is
the sound or the human voice
and the lyrics.
And no computer will
ever emulate that.
I just don't think
it's possible.
SHIRLEY MANSON: Never say never.
[LAUGHTER]
BUTCH VIG: I just don't think--
I can't see it being authentic.
I can't see a computer
being authentic.
SHIRLEY MANSON: 20 years
ago, we were, well,
you were, not so much
me, but directly involved
with Christopher
Bock of Digidesign.
And he was very
involved in working
with the band, the
men in particular
here, because at
this point, I was
totally uninterested in anything
technological, truth be told.
But you were on the phone
with him constantly, I
felt, back then.
BUTCH VIG: Like I said,
we're curious today.
I could see using sort of
algorithms and computers,
to come up with sounds
that might start a song,
or might take it somewhere
that you wouldn't know,
that you wouldn't
be ready to go to.
Because we have a sensibility.
If we plug in guitars or
drums, we play a certain way.
But I think if you introduce
something that can give you
a different
perspective, it might
shape the way a
Garbage song goes,
and that could be really cool.
I think that's why we're really
interested in seeing what kind
of technology you all got.
LAURA PARAGANO:
Absolutely, I can't
wait to see if you make
something completely brand
new out of it.
BUTCH VIG: Yeah.
LAURA PARAGANO: I
think maybe it's
going to be time soon to
open up the floor to Q and A.
So we're going to have
a mic in the back.
If anybody would like to
step up, or make a line,
by all means, we'd love to
hear what you've got to ask.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
STEVE MARKER: Hi.
AUDIENCE: So, understandably,
this conversation
has been pretty focused
on how technology
interacts with the process of
music production itself, right?
What I'm wondering is,
as technology sort of
has like broader cultural
implications, how
those sort of effect the
music that you all are making.
For example, and I'm sorry,
this is a very personal thing
for me, you have a song,
"Androgyny," which spoke
to me at a really young age.
And I mean, I don't
know, I probably
wasn't old enough at the
time to sort of understand
how it was broadly perceived,
but I have to imagine,
given its lyrical content,
that it was pretty progressive
for the time.
Now, those sentiments-- sorry,
I can't recite the lyrics,
are more broadly shared.
So I'm wondering, as technology
has sort of shaped culture
more broadly, has that
affected sort of how you all
think about your music and sort
of what you're speaking to?
Does that make sense?
SHIRLEY MANSON: It
does make sense.
Again, I don't think it's
necessarily changed the way
we want to make music.
What it has changed is the
galvanization of ideas.
Something like androgyny, back
then, was perceived as a little
out there.
And nowadays, I feel
like these messages
that deal with taboos or deal
with things that are considered
still marginalized voices,
through the Internet,
we can find our people
and find our base.
And it's been an incredible
tool in that regard,
of like pinpointing where
people's sympathies lie
and where you share an
ideology or philosophy.
And that has also worked also
to all of our detriments.
But it's also a
beautiful, amazing thing,
that you can find your audience
much faster and broader,
and all over the world.
And that's incredible.
And I think it
connects people who
have felt marginalized in ways
that we've never seen before.
And I think that's
why we are beginning
to see a lot of change
in a certain field.
And it's exciting.
I mean, we've all got
a long ways to go,
but it's still pretty rad that
we can all galvanize and stand
behind things that we
believe so strongly in.
Does that answer your question?
I'm so sorry--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SHIRLEY MANSON: Thank you.
I like your shade of lipstick.
It's similar to mine.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: I wanted to ask about
"Version 2.0," 20 years later,
now that you guys are
looking back on that album,
is there anything that you would
have changed about that album,
or songs that you
would have included,
like "Soldier Through
This"-- it would
have made me so happy to
see that on the album.
DUKE ERIKSON: That's obviously
one of your favorites.
I think that we're really proud
of this record the way it is.
I think any time you put
out something like that,
you can look back at it 20
years later, and two days later,
and think maybe you should have
done this a little different
or that.
But it is what it is.
And we worked really hard
on it for a long time.
And the "Soldier Through
This" and songs, those B-sides
all came after the
record, for the most part.
They were B-sides
that were demanded
that we record for
single releases in the UK
and so forth.
So that was a later one.
But some of the B-sides,
we think are pretty strong.
And they were written in like 10
minutes and recorded in a day.
I don't know why we didn't
do the whole album that way.
Thanks for the question.
SHIRLEY MANSON:
Thank you, though.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for
thanks for being here.
I have a question
about ownership.
It sounds like you
value ownership
over the process of
music production.
When you use platforms,
like social media platforms,
you don't have a lot
of ownership over you
how you communicate
with your fans.
Like for example, Facebook
might change a policy,
like you cannot send group
messages anymore without paying
for it.
Like those kinds of
things, you give away
a certain part of control over
communicating with your fans.
How do deal with that?
And then, how does
that affect you?
SHIRLEY MANSON: We've
had more control
over how we communicate with our
fans now than we've ever done.
So things change, and
you have to adapt.
I mean, as an artist, if
you don't adapt, you die.
It's as simple as that.
If you refuse to move with the
changes, you'll be drowned.
And we're lucky that
we worked with a man
that we've trusted for a long
time, our manager, Paul Kremen.
We worked with him
at the beginning,
and he's been with us
throughout our entire career
at this point.
And he originally ran our
record label, basically.
And because he has a great
background in marketing
and has a great
grasp of industry,
he has forced us
at times to adapt.
And we've strongly fought him.
And that's been
fights, and hysteria,
and me telling someone
to [INAUDIBLE]..
But he has pushed
us to sort of--
embrace streaming,
for a random example.
Which we were so
against and offended by.
And are still offended by the
way musicians are compensated.
But as Paul so
rightly pointed out,
better to be compensated a
small amount than no amount.
So things like that, we have
people around us that really
push us to sort of
try and stay on top
of the changes in social
media and in technology.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
SHIRLEY MANSON: Hello.
AUDIENCE: One of the
things you mentioned
is, you talked about how the
technology from the early days
kind of caught up in maybe
what was strange or weird
or, as an Indie kid, myself
probably liked [INAUDIBLE]
back in the day.
Is there anything in technology
today that kind of something
new, or even maybe
something musicians
are doing with technology, that
kind of seems new today that
interests you at all?
SHIRLEY MANSON: Well,
the VR stuff for a start,
I mean, holy cow.
That's mind boggling
what people are
beginning to achieve
with that and where
they're going with that.
And mixing sounds with
visuals, and I think
that's kind of blown us away.
STEVE MARKER: That's what really
interests me moving forward,
the mixed reality stuff and
augmented reality stuff.
It's going to be amazing.
BUTCH VIG: I really like a lot
of the new virtual instruments
that are coming out, especially
the sound design type ones.
I mean, there's a ton of great
pianos, and organs, and synths,
but I sort of
gravitate to the ones,
like using Reactor and
Native instruments.
There's always super cool,
hard to describe platforms
you can get for them, like
one called [INAUDIBLE],,
which just makes the
most insane noise.
You can't even really
program it at all.
And it's made by a third party,
I don't even know who makes it.
But I find all that
stuff interesting.
I had a background in
film when I went to UW.
And I like textures in sound.
You can hear that in a
lot of Garbage songs.
There's a lot of layers of sort
of subversive sounding things
in the background.
And so I'm constantly
sort of tinkering
with a lot of those
new plug-ins that
gets sounds that are atypical
from stock instrumental sounds.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for being here.
So "The World is Not
Enough," still to this day
my favorite "James Bond" song.
[APPLAUSE]
And there have been
plenty of them.
My question is being featured
in a movie like that, what kind
of an impact do you think
it had on the longevity
of your career?
SHIRLEY MANSON: I think
it had quite an impact.
I mean, that kind of exposure
it gave us was insane.
We had never seen
anything like it, really.
And to have a big movie
company behind us was intense.
I mean, it was not the
easiest of partnerships.
The music business
is like a playground
compared to the movie business.
There's a lot of
investment involved
and a lot of interference that
we didn't take too kindly to.
BUTCH VIG: No, we didn't, no.
[LAUGHTER]
SHIRLEY MANSON: But to
have that in our arsenal
is extraordinary.
It's still a thrill.
Every night, I'm like I cannot
believe I'm singing a "Bond"
song, this is mad, you know.
So, yeah, we were very
fortunate to get that
at that particular
moment in our career.
And it just sort of topped--
it was the cherry on the top
of our really successful record
campaign of "Version 2.0."
And just sort of as
everything was dwindling,
we got this incredible gig.
And it allowed our touring
to continue for another six
to eight months.
And so it was
extraordinarily fortuitous.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
STEVE MARKER: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Shirley, you've
been a very strong role
model for women over the years.
Do you ever find that--
do you find that important
or intimidating in any way?
SHIRLEY MANSON: I don't
really think of it,
to be honest, in those terms.
I just try and live my life
the way I think is appropriate.
I have been quite
blown away by the love
that I've received
from a lot of women.
And it is a great honor
for me anytime a woman
comes up and says, you
helped me with this,
or something you said
spurred me to do that.
But I never think
of myself in any way
as a good example of humanity.
[LAUGHTER]
I mean, I'm lucky.
I don't know why I'm like
this, but I don't really
think about it very much.
And I think that's
probably just as well.
Maybe that keeps me sane.
But I am a feminist.
I believe in the
principles of feminism.
I feel now, more than ever,
women are under siege,
and I want to speak up about it.
And particularly for
women, black women,
and for colored women,
these are treacherous times
we're living in.
And so now more than ever,
I make myself speak up,
even when it's uncomfortable.
Because I think it's an outrage.
I think what's going
on in America currently
is an outrage.
And it breaks my heart.
[APPLAUSE]
BUTCH VIG: Here-here.
SHIRLEY MANSON: So,
yeah, but we press on.
We will endure.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for coming.
This is so awesome.
You mentioned that
you, in live shows,
you use a lot of sequencers
to preserve your sound.
How does that
affect your ability
to maybe improvise, be in the
moment, react to the crowd
and to the moment?
STEVE MARKER: We've
got the technology now
so we can change things
up to a certain extent
pretty easily, if
in the sound check,
we feel like something's
the wrong tempo
or something like that.
Butch is able now to--
we can go to any song
pretty much that we know,
and it doesn't have
to be a locked in set
if we don't want it to be.
So it's a little more flexible.
We're not a jam band and
don't want to be either.
So we've got to a comfortable
place now I'd say.
BUTCH VIG: Steve hates that
term jamming, by the way.
He just hates it.
[LAUGHTER]
STEVE MARKER: Yeah.
BUTCH VIG: You know, if
you hear any of our shows,
we try to play exactly the
same, as perfect as we can
every night, and
we're not even close.
Every night it's different.
The guitar riffs are a
little bit different,
my drumming changes.
Shirley ad libs
vocals all the time.
So every night is--
its own thing.
And we realized a
long time ago, we
don't want to sound exactly
like our album anymore.
If that were the case, just
put the album on, and the PA,
and we'll just set up
on stage and dance.
So recording is one thing.
And music should be
listened to that way.
When you go see a
live experience,
it should just be that
moment in the room.
And every night should be
a little bit different.
SHIRLEY MANSON: But we
are currently limited.
But I'm sure that's
going to change.
Where I would imagine at some
point, we'll get to the point
where the brain at the back,
the machine at the back
can adapt really quickly.
So I would imagine,
in my wildest dreams,
that by a flick of a button,
we can elongate a section,
shorten a section.
I mean, that would be
amazing if we could do that.
DUKE ERIKSON: Work
on that, will you?
SHIRLEY MANSON: Yeah, if
somebody here could come up
with that, that would be wild.
BUTCH VIG: I'm sure the could.
AUDIENCE: Actually a
quick follow up to that.
When your tours
are being booked,
are you asking for
certain types of venues?
Because sometimes certain
groups will sound terrible
in a real boomy
place, and some groups
might want a really
small club atmosphere.
Are you pushing for a
certain type of venue?
Or is that just out
of your control?
And do you recompose if you're
in a venue that's just going
to sound terrible otherwise?
SHIRLEY MANSON: [LAUGHS] You
make me feel really inadequate.
[LAUGHTER]
STEVE MARKER: Really.
SHIRLEY MANSON: Yeah, we have no
control really over the venues
we play, unfortunately.
I mean, we often
step into a venue,
and you'll realize
that the PA is stacked
behind the mic,
which means you're
in for a bad night,
things like that.
And there's nothing you can do.
You can't re-hang a PA.
So, yeah, it's complicated and
a bit of a nightmare sometimes.
But you just have
to get on with it.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, I noticed that.
That's why our sound
engineer's been struggling,
it's like you're
screwed, basically.
But, yeah, what were
you going to say?
BUTCH VIG: It's sort of
what you're saying too.
For me, the first thing, I
get up and hit the bass drum,
and sometimes it's just
tight and other times, boom,
it comes back like
four seconds later,
twice as loud as
when you hit it.
And that affects
everybody on the stage.
And we're like, oh, my god,
this is going to be a nightmare.
And unfortunately,
our monitor mixer,
he probably has a heart attack
through most of the set,
because every song, he's
struggling to try and get
our mixes dialed in.
You realize you just
have to roll with it,
because every stage
does sound different.
AUDIENCE: Hey, guys.
So actually, this question
is really for Butch.
So Butch, before the
inception of Garbage,
you were a fairly well-known
person in the music industry.
And you may have
just produced one
of the most generational
albums of all time,
from this triplet
from the Seattle area.
So if you were to--
I have two questions on this.
If you were to do
"Nevermind" again,
would you change something,
knowing what you know today?
And then, second question-- this
is a really minute question.
My favorite song of that
album is "Drain You"
because the intro of that song--
I don't know, as an
amateur producer,
I don't no idea how you did it.
BUTCH VIG: Which song?
AUDIENCE: "Drain You"
with Kurt Cobain.
BUTCH VIG: With all those
little sound effects?
Right?
Are there little--
AUDIENCE: It just starts with
Kurt Cobain singing and playing
the guitar and the guitar
sounds like ridiculously--
BUTCH VIG: Oh, yeah, [SINGING]
AUDIENCE: Exactly, that one.
BUTCH VIG: Well, to
answer the first question,
if I produced
"Nevermind" now, there's
a good chance I
might fuck it up.
[LAUGHTER]
Because I'd probably
use Pro Tools,
and we probably would not
have gone to Sound City.
I mean, there was a
combination of things.
The band rehearsed for six
months every single day.
They were tight when
we went in there.
The sound of that room,
Sound City, is amazing.
Dave Grohl had just
joined the band.
He's one of the best drummers,
rock drummers in the world.
They had written
brilliant songs.
That Neve board in Sound
City has a sound to it.
So there were all
those X factors.
But then there's also
the factor of the time
that people were looking
for a record like that.
If "Nevermind" came
out today, there's
no way it would have
the same impact.
It just wouldn't.
It would be scrutinized
in social media,
like Shirley said, probably
dead in 48 or 72 hours.
People would move on
to something else.
It wouldn't have
that sort of magic,
because it came out at a time,
when I think people, coming out
the '80s, I think
they were looking
for some sort of
profound change.
And that album
resonated with people.
I was very lucky, we all were,
that it was the right timing
for that record.
"Drain You," I can't
really remember,
I think the guitar
sound is probably--
I think Kurt probably played--
he had [INAUDIBLE] and I
think I brought in a Box AC30
for a lot of the clean guitars.
I'm pretty sure we used
a Box AC30 on the intro.
LAURA PARAGANO:
Unfortunately, I think
that is all the time
that we have for today.
Thank you so much
for taking the time.
SHIRLEY MANSON:
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]